Try by day Joe Rogan podcast by night.
All Day.
So how,
how long can you hold on?
I personally know I could go a week
without water from my cuts and one 55 so
I know I could do a week.
Yeah.
And that'd be after that.
I'm on my,
I'm on my death bed.
Yeah Dude,
let's talk about that.
Don't do that anymore.
Don't do that anymore after that.
I know you keep talking about like
fighting Eddie Alvarez cause you already
beat him and now he's the champ.
But God damn,
you're looking good at one 70 yeah.
So you say I didn't look good if 55 I've
sensation with 55 nine for 10 70 on my
last run world beater man,
it's,
it's not just that you look good,
it's just the way you look.
It's like you,
you,
you hit a whole new level.
And I always wonder like is it because
obviously you keep training,
obviously you keep getting better.
Obviously you work hard,
all those things,
learning from experience,
all those things are a factor.
But on top of that,
there's also the factor of you not
having a cut that fucking wait man.
So this last fight against rick story
against Rick Story.
It looked like you were in the fucking
matrix.
That was some Anderson Silva's shit.
I ate five guys three nights that we
were in Vegas.
Five guys Burgers,
hamburger,
double doubles.
I'm a food bacon and of those
[inaudible] and it was on though.
Of course.
Yeah.
You get the Jalapeno did the season,
the season fries.
Of course my trainers are happier.
Yeah.
I mean I think I had six pounds to cut.
It was an easy no brainer.
Yeah.
But when I saw you before the fight,
before that,
you were a one 76 when you were at the
comedy store.
Yeah.
That's nothing.
Nothing.
Yeah.
Look how good you look at this way.
I feel good.
That's for damn sure.
But it's not a factor.
I mean,
look how fast you are.
Like the Kobe fight,
dude,
you were on fire.
You're on fire at that weight.
Yeah.
I Dunno.
What's the thought process can do one 55
right?
You can do it.
You have what you want.
It's like 60 or 65 or 65 weight class
that be capitol.
He's like class,
but it's just that last five pounds.
His death for me.
Fucking brutal.
You know,
from 60 to 55 I just feel like I got
nothing left man.
I don't know if that carries over like,
like I want to ask,
you see pedis slipped a little tired.
Indian,
his last fight.
I don't know if the 45 cut,
if that has something to do with that
for sure.
If it tastes the,
if your gas tank a little hundred
percent a hundred percent it has to.
It has to,
right?
Yeah.
I feel great out there.
That's what I'm fucking love fighting
and this is my favorite thing in the
whole world to do a and the whole world.
Like I wish a,
all the,
when I leave here pulls up in parking
lot and tried to get some shit like that
to me,
you know,
and this is the way,
it's the craziest thing to me.
People tell me like I posted version of
me flipping people off,
right?
So they're like,
gobble,
you were fucking role model.
How dare you?
Like no I'm not.
I'm a,
I'm a bar junkie.
That fights all the time and you guys
all on tv and you think is cool.
So you,
I'm your favorite fire.
You know?
But had you not be in the USC,
I'd be the asshole trying to take your
girlfriend if fight you at the bar just
as you're now.
That's who I would be.
You.
You know how many people sent me and the
animated Gif of that final combination
you landed on rick stories.
Talk about that.
Oh,
let's throw that up on the screen.
Well let's,
let's talk.
So everyone says how great this convoys,
oh,
it's beautiful.
Okay,
here it is.
All crack.
That's the end of it.
It was wash it from the beginning.
Well,
you know what I love about it man.
What I love,
I love technique.
Look at this.
This is what I love.
Pop to the body,
to the head.
Boom.
You know what I love about it?
Not a single one of those techniques is
wound up.
full power.
But look how you doing this pop bank,
crack blind.
So for everyone that's listening,
all that is the jab,
cross,
Hook,
kick.
Yeah,
but it's not,
because here's the thing about it,
the way you throwing all these things is
the way everybody should throw every
punch your,
there's no windup.
Everything is perfect technique.
The execution,
the timing,
the,
the accuracy.
Look how beautiful this is,
man.
See,
this is used.
So I bet it's hard for you to
appreciate.
But for me as a person who calls MMA as
a person who watches fights do,
when I was calling that fight,
I was like this.
I was like,
Oh,
oh,
oh look at this.
Oh,
this is perfect.
Do you know how upset I missed the
triangle I am with myself?
Oh my God,
he's a tough guy.
He's got good submission defense.
So last time we talked,
we talk about Calvin watching himself.
Like I'm playing a video game.
I was in the mode for sure.
Yeah,
for sure.
That's a matrix.
Shit.
I mean,
this to me is more impressive than when
Anderson Silva knocked out forrest
griffin because when Anderson Silva
knocked out forrest Griffin,
what I know about forest was that force
was compromised going into that fight.
He had been knocked out twice and
training camp.
He had a real hard time taking shots and
probably shouldn't have been in there in
the first place.
And so he had a lot of doubts and he was
having a real hard time.
This is a big powerful rick story who's
a nasty motherfucker.
He throws vicious body shots.
He's a hard wrestler.
He's the guy who was the first lost that
Johnny Hendricks got.
People don't know Rick Story.
Rick Story's a tough dude and for you to
tee off on him like this in this perfect
way,
not with big wound up fucking heavy
shots like he throws with Rick.
Story likes to do as he pressures guys
and he fucking digs in or I wound to the
body,
takes you down,
beats you up.
He's got a tough,
tough dude and what you did is you just
use perfect technique.
That angle.
When you throw that left,
you throw the LE,
you throw the Left,
the Jab,
you throw the right hand to the body and
then you take that watch this jab.
Well he,
he did.
Boom.
That was all luck.
You would just,
did you adjust it perfectly?
What?
That left.
He tried to be nice.
He tried to be nice to put yourself look
good.
It's a beautiful combination today.
That's a matrix shit and I feel like a
big part of that is you not depleting
your body.
Absolutely.
Another big part of his and one 70
pounders don't think you can just come
take my body shots anymore because I
don't,
I got a little more biscuit now.
Yeah,
right.
You don't,
you don't have to.
We body.
Jesus.
What did you body feel like when you
fought one 55 like when you compare
yourself to a normal training session,
like say you're several months in
between.
I'll walk around one s I used to walk
around bow one 74 right?
That was like my deep training camp and
I noticed when I started to cut,
I'd get down to one 68 one 70 but I had
nothing in the gas tank man.
I would always be like,
it would all mentor at that point,
you know?
And I didn't have,
like,
my body felt real thin and brittle and
one 70 I feel good.
I don't feel the,
I got the,
I got the extra tank,
you know?
Yeah.
I don't feel like it's a big part of it.
Oh my God.
Is it?
It's a big part of it,
man.
Okay.